douce en bretagne la direction
départementale du travail dépose une
plainte auprès du tribunal correctionnel
de brest contre une entreprise de sous
traitance nucléaire
à l'origine de cette affaire le cas d'un
ancien électricien atteint aujourd'hui
de leucémie et invalide à 80% ce
reportage le cardio et diane richards le
jour où il a appris qu'il allait prendre
ce bateau pour travailler sur l'île
longue en juin 96
dominique keyria s'étaient réjouis car
c'était une promotion
l'électricien déry mère aurait en charge
l'éclairage des sous marins nucléaires
pendant leurs périodes de cale sèche en
particulier dans la zone des missiles
quand je suis arrivé sur le site
mondy certains militaires les militaires
nous ont pas aidés musicale qu'on se
sait que toi t'as pas ce site à placer
âge c'est quoi ceci cela là ce sont des
films dosimétriques trail est incertain
ils ont fait quoi maintenant je peux me
sens je travaille pas les endroits
risqués ni film dosimétriques ni visite
médicale préventive jusqu'au 7 juillet
97 lorsqu'il est hospitalisé d'urgence
pour une leucémie aiguë dominique
querrien continue de travailler sans
protection pourtant dès le mois de
décembre 96 soit sept mois plus tôt dans
une note interne des autorités de l'île
longue reconnaissent le risque de
rayonnements ionisants précisément dans
la zone où ils travaillent
on a demandé à rencontrer ceux qui sont
responsables des procédures et on a
demandé à visiter à nous montrer qu'elle
était le dispositif réellement mise en
oeuvre pour garantir aux salariés qu'ils
étaient dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
on n'a pas accédé à notre demande pour
l'instant après un an de vérification la
sécurité sociale a reconnu le caractère
professionnel de la leucémie de
dominique keyria surtout cette affaire a
réveillé la soif de transparence de
certains élus de brest d exigence
d'autant plus compréhensible que la
ville n'a toujours pas de plan
particulier d'intervention pour les
installations nucléaires qui l'ont aussi
quelqu'un qui travaille sur le site a du
mal à faire reconnaître une difficulté
qui là qu'il a eue
comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir passer
un plan particulier d'intervention qui
concerne les populations civiles
invalide à 80% dans l'impossibilité
d'exercer un travail avant août 2001
dominique querrien est aujourd'hui
bénévole dans une association de soutien
scolaire un moyen de refuser de voir sa
vie confinée entre l'hôpital et les
tribunaux la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme à strasbourg demande à la
turquie de surseoir à l'exécution d'un
double out jalonnent le chef kurde été
condamné je vous le rappelle à mort pour
trahison et séparatisme un chancelier à
paris gerhardt schröder a exprimé devant
l'assemblée nationale sa vision
politique de l'europe est mise en avant
l'amitié franco allemande
paris et berlin ont donné une nouvelle
impulsion à l'europe de la défense en
publiant à l'issue de ce 64e sommet une
déclaration faisant état de futur moyens
militaires mettre en place les autres
temps forts de l'actualité
internationale et on commence par
l'irlande du nord les lords britanniques
ont adopté la loi qui délègue les
pouvoirs au tout nouveau gouvernement du
ster d ilog grande émotion dans la
communauté protestante d'irlande du nord
après la nomination de martin mcguinness
comme ministre de l'éducation nationale
il exercera au sein du nouveau
gouvernement autonome et biconfessionnel
dirigé par david trimble le catholique
martin mcguinness symbolise la lutte
armée républicaine des trente dernières
années
les neuf autres ministres nommés hier
devront prendre leurs fonctions jeudi à
minuit le parlement anglais a jusqu'à
cette date pour débattre de la
rétrocession de ses prérogatives dans
des domaines comme l'économie
l'agriculture l'éducation ou la santé
l'irak accuse la grande bretagne et les
etats unis d'avoir bombardé des cibles
civiles au sud de son territoire
le pentagone a démenti mais reconnaît la
tacc d'une base aérienne au nord du pays
le ministère irakien de la formation a
emmené des journalistes dans une école
qui aurait été bombardé lundi selon
l'institutrice dix enfants auraient été
blessées helmut kohl au centre d'un
scandale de financement occulte de
l'union chrétienne démocrate
l'ancien chancelier allemand a admis
aujourd'hui que des erreurs proche de
l'illégalité ont été commises sous sa
direction des comptes auraient été
pilotées indépendamment du parti
wolfgang schaeuble
l'actuel dirigeant de les céder ou a mis
en cause son prédécesseur en parlant de
la gestion patriarcal de celui ci et
nous colle était arrivé la tête du parti
conservateur allemand en 1973 son mandat
a duré 25 ans si vous n'avez pas encore
acheté votre vignette vous savez ce qui
vous reste à faire demain matin juste
après le café 1er décembre date butoir
sinon gare à la majoration de 5 %
passé cette date la vignette ne sera
plus disponible que dans les recettes
des impôts parmi les autres achats un
peu plus réjouissant de ce mois de
décembre il ya bien sûr les cadeaux de
noël est incontournable le téléphone
portable
les chiffres sont impressionnants 20
millions de français posséderont un
mobile d'ici au 31 décembre enquête
elisabeth est scellé et joli bout serre
on sait plus à quelle sonnerie se vouer
ni laquelle forfait ni à quelle sphère
où mère noël
la chasse aux nouveaux abonnés fait rage
les opérateurs ont leurs raisons
fan siècle oblige l'enjeu est de taille
nous pensons qu'il y aura deux millions
de clients au minimum qui vont s'équiper
d'un téléphone mobile pendant le mois de
décembre dont nous ce que nous attendons
nous avons pris le parti de déclarer que
nous voulions démocratiser l'usagé du
téléphone mobile donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle dont nous communiquons et
avec cet objectif d'étendre à tous les
usages du téléphone mobile
pour attirer le maximum de nouveaux
clients les opérateurs ne pouvait pas
démocratiser davantage tous ces
portables à condition de s'abonner sont
vendus 1 franc et ce ne sont pas de
vieux couples modèles récents haut de
gamme qui acheté seul coûte entre 2000
et 2500 francs
ça plaît c'est une façon comme une autre
pour les opérateurs de d'avoir une clé
de capter une clientèle donc bien c'est
pas nouveau mais c'était à 200 france a
été à 500 à new york
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir fait une
bonne affaire je pense vu le peu plus le
faisant vous avez payé sur paris il ya
trois ans de sagelat vp avec le forfait
c'était ça m'a coûté 1000 francs début
aussi les commerçants aussi sont ravis
puisqu'ils multiplient leurs ventes en
touchant la même commission que sur les
appareils plus cher c'est l'opérateur
qui finance en se rattrapant sur la
quantité et sur le prix des abonnements
et des communications c'est là que le
bât blesse
les consommateurs se plaignent de
contrats hermétique et de services
coûtent facturé d'office mais cela ne
les empêche pas d'abandonner leur
téléphone fixe 10% de français ont
remplacé leurs bonnes vieilles ding par
un portable
beaucoup d'entre vous rivalisent déjà
d'imagination pour organiser un
réveillon digne de ce passage à l'an
2000 voilà quelqu un en tout cas qui ne
risque pas d'être taxé de conformisme il
s'appelle michel siffre et les
spéléologues il entamé dans l'après midi
son expérience hors du temps dans la
grotte de clamouse dans l'hérault une
chose est sûre il passera bien en 2000
mais il ne sera pas précisément à quel
moment puisqu'il coupé du monde
mais celle ci ferait est un pionnier
dans ce genre d'expérience qui vise à
tester leur loge interne de l'être
humain
il fêtera son 61e anniversaire sous
terre le 3 janvier une façon originale
d'enterrer l'année 99
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant le très beau film de ken loach
carla song demain j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver aux alentours d'une heure
molcard excellent tenu à tous
à demain
tous
excellent tenu à toutes et à tous
grisaille au nord et soleil au succès le
programme météo pour ce mercredi avec
une perturbation qui parvient à
s'infiltrer à l'intérieur des terres
donnera de faibles pluies sur une petite
moitié nord entre ces deux zones parce
que au sud il fera beau encore avec la
présence de brume et de brouillard donc
entre ces deux zones les biens ciel très
nuageux avec là encore des brumes des
brouillards dans les vallées et quelques
averses très localisés en ce qui
concerne l'après midi on retrouve cette
perturbation elle va se désactiver si
avec les averses seront plus rares en
revanche de belles éclaircies vont
revenir sur le nord sur la picardie et
puis au sud ce sera encore du soleil
avec la préférence de quelques cumulus
de beau temps
côté températures elles seront en légère
hausse notamment au nord avec débat ou
créer jc par vous plaisez à la caméra
vous avez eu d'excellents réflexes
je vous donne votre chance comme
reporter
j'ai passé pour vous le dire vous pensez
que je voulais vous sauter
nous je crois je viens d'avoir une
promotion
tout ça c'est du remplissage dans ce
reportage
harvey rencontre d'un sujet non
le coût des allégations du week-end
c'est quoi au sujet de la mode des bacs
à south beach et c'était là ils sont
partis on attendait le sujet c'est tout
regardons le deuxième bobino ici y'a pas
moyen de sauver quelque chose
l'un des meilleurs fabricants signalent
depuis pas font de bonnes affaires
c'est quoi ce sujet cette fois les
cubains ou vous et votre cigare à cuba
je voulais dire alors vous auriez dû
comprendre que cet exil et là qui
fabrique ce cigare n'est pas un vrai
produit à vannes mais un ex agent de
batista ces réserves est tombé en panne
il nous faut combien de temps pour
arriver à limoux beach je croyais qu'on
était censé couvrir cette saloperie de
salon nautique et leurs conneries drague
à notre sujet il nous faut combien dans
une demi heure pig will est allé écouter
net dit qu'on est vraiment hâte de
parler d'art mais tout est mal
à
le coq en jacques sur matoub est sur les
dents en mai mais si jamais il arrive
trop tard il faut quelqu'un pour le
direct qui sort vous voulez encore
jamais fait vous avez pas de quoi il
s'agit
ned film le bateau les balcons et outils
le porte parole
expliquez-moi de quoi il s'agit a dit ok
voyons ce que vous avez dans le ventre
rentrer là-dedans traduit bien le micro
c'est quoi respecter
je suis désolé je ne peux pas confirmer
leurs nationalités je vous le dirai que
dès que je le ferais mais d'abord il
faut les sauver le château d'eau est ce
que vous vous y prenez ces livres
procédure habituelle
quelle est la méthode pour identifier et
n'a connu oui je suis ravi de jouer mais
moi j'en ai fait ce n'est pas la hauteur
prendrait le relais pour l'instant vous
l'affairé erwan x10 ou alors il
s'appelle juan x et / ou est ce que
c'est votre façon de souvent pardon et
cette personne dont le nom resterait
encore à préciser était d'origine
hispano américaine fait l'esprit bon
écoutez je vous demanderai de faire
preuve d'un peu de pression
en attendant les précisions des gosses
de la rue lenteur les noyers flop parce
qu'ils ont la garde dans le ventre c'est
ce qui les fait remonter quelques fois
on n'a qu'à se mettre la ciotat domingo
quatre colombiens ils s'étaient tous les
deux sous qui est sur le coup dit mary
sont volontairement sauté par dessus
bord j'ai téléphoner avec un kit ennery
un reporter appelle toujours les
autorités avant même de se déplacer et
des bingos cad
on a encore le band en vainqueur la
forte tempête qui a balayé miami notoire
non pas ailleurs c'est aujourd'hui d'un
four sont fourvière où je suis
aujourd'hui 9 ou 10 hockey balle jaune
et rouge croise avec la meilleure que
celle ci sera également la date ou de
sentir sa vie tu m'entends bien
on passe dans combien de temps ok dans
une minute 12 secondes ça vous de paris
que ce coût mais non ce pas le moment il
s'agit pas de votre physique il s'agit
de deux pour vandières house hotel
domingo carte de malheureux qui ont
trouvé la mort à quelques mètres de
l'eldorado passé ne savait pas nager
on n'apprend pas nager quand on
s'appelle quatre sous le sceau tas et
qu'on est colombien c'est ça le sujet
paraît tombeur de couler à pic
une minute une minute ok
dans les eaux bleues de miami
aujourd'hui ajouté domingo cats pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont marqués ce qu'il
voulait dans les eaux bleues de miami
beach aujourd'hui les calendriers on ne
m'a rien à [ __ ] des scaphandriers
aller directement house se taillent
domino casse je vous dirai ce que je
sais ce qu'il faut dire l'article
c'est à dominique quelques mètres du
gâteau à quelques mètres de la terre
promise
à quelques mètres de la liberté des
restaurants de collins avenue où on peut
être engagée comme plongeur tout le
monde est content que ça doit être
d'être à ce point désespérée disent ben
warren
non mais vous rendez compte oui c'est
rouge et le noir europe n'a plus rien à
ajouter c'est à elle dans cette seconde
racontez moi une histoire qu'à deux
hommes se sont noyés aujourd'hui au
large de miami beach
raul soda et domingo cas ce n'était pas
de ceux qui possèdent des luxueuses
kevin debaty bord de cette plage ils ont
sauté d'un bateau il voulait vivre en
amérique
ils sont morts leurs corps sans vie ont
fini par échouer sur une plage de la
terre promise il ya une aire sur la lys
qu'on sait si ces hommes cherchaient
l'asile politique tally à toi long
voyage au départ de barranquilla en
colombie c'est l'apport qui attendait
aujourd'hui raul7 à et domine caucase
s'était allié à twitter de miami beach
et que c'était les doigts et l'api
c'est vous
et autant
vous dois une fière chandelle c'est ça
très joli le reportage sur les
clandestins si brusquement je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y en a beaucoup comme
eux tous les jours qu'ils réussissent à
s'infiltrer
ça fait réfléchir ah oui et je ne voyais
pas tarder
un petit conseil de la part de l'ampleur
robe méfiez-vous de warren ne le laissez
pas vous propulser trop vite
si vous cherchez un mentor robert in ne
rien
ce soir un grand débat d'actualité l'air
et il y aura un stand mais pas le ta
pratique quand il ya neuf à la dgi a
interviewé fidel castro elle l'a fait en
espagnol oui évidemment mais dites moi
avant votre tête à tête avec fidel si
vous vous achetez un nouveau tie heure
ou deux nous avons une consultante très
compétente guinness fuentes d'accord on
a un budget pas ça il faut pas que
l'objet ne le spectateur tout en tentant
warren veut quelque chose de fringants
d'accord
c'est le genre de type qu'il faut
demandait depuis quand il a cessé de
battre sa femme pour lui faire dire
qu'il n'a pas mis à jour à jamais ses
accointances avec les cartes et s'ils
refusent de répondre à ces questions
devant la caméra nous aurait rendu
compte et d'autre part c'est a jadis un
vrai c'est assez fringants inès pour les
cheveux on peut faire quelque chose
j'écoute pas il n'en est pas question
vous avez gagné
monsieur le député je répondais à ceux
qui disent que votre campagne financée
par le trafic de recul sur n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour est-il exact que
plusieurs personnalités étrangères plus
utile à la petite boîte posée c'est sûr
maintenant cette campagne dites lui que
j'ai retrouvé la mère du transsexuel
oui celui sur lequel de la u a fait
toute une émission
c'est du réchauffé oui je sais je
regrette dites lui que c'est tout ce que
j'ai solution de liberté de la presse
avoir un contrat que les maires des
transsexuels maintenant non pour la
couleur locale ici c'est pas l'idéal
dites lui que je serai la havane jeudi
soir nancy mois 2 1
protégée par un imposant service d'ordre
les vitres en verre fumé de sa voiture
une mygale
je parie que c'est une de ces créatures
ça y est quel con si diane tally à toi
de johanna kainry johanna et mon
ex-épouse in de saison celle qui m'a
quittée à washington ou l'autre m'a
quittée à la nouvelle orléans johanna
est en route pour la vague qui ne veut
pas venir avec moi je te laisse le temps
de réfléchir
vous vous étiez imaginer que diantre et
comprend que je vais vous montrer les
miracles qu'on peut faire monter les
enchères et juste l'amener devant la
caméra y joue fine registre moins
d'ambiance et tourner quelques plans sur
les stands hockey et des ballons surtout
pas tremblé et vous comment auriez-vous
fait ça à la perfection
j'adore mes valeurs
attendez vous allez voir garder on va
faire un fondu sur la vitre pour
enchaîner sur vous la jeune fille sont
dites moi m oui johanna jeunes elle
pensait que j'avais mes entrées au sénat
ce qui était vrai à l'époque notre
groupe la sphère dans les beaux
dimanches de l'info télévisée mais nous
voir quelqu'un on dit pat le matin c'est
pas ma tasse de thé
voilà on à vos questions des images de
ballon rond l'ambiance au non plus ça ne
doit pas être votre tasse de thé
peut-être pas
la barque
en jouant montage
on fait des merveilles et sur notre la
chance de l'or
oui
on s'en va
des enfants et les jeunes
non akerys j'ai eu un oui ma première
femme
on a eu une petite fille
elle n'a vécu que les jours
la famille vus in serre
deux points jour j il veut quand on a
perdu notre mère maman à exploser sa
voiture sur l'autoroute
elle aurait voulu être chanteuse
malheureusement il n'a jamais rien elle
connaissait tout le répertoire de betty
page
c'était quelqu'un de bien
c'est j'ai déjà vécu ça plusieurs fois
aussi
prentice ne quittez pas
c'est pour vous voir
alors oui
ni toi
je te rapelle de chez moi
où
je dois m'absenter quelques jours
problèmes n'ont aucun problème vous êtes
obligé de partir c'est personnel
tout l'argent je suis là
sacha v
erding
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le groupe
oméga
le procès en appel qui comptait sept
steve va l'faire site à y rentrer demain
après midi
elle prendra le relais il faut pas
compter sur elle il ya là quant à lui
faire parvenir un mandat
non les sages nos charges dit adan que
arni paul arrive en fin de contrat san
francisco et que je pars chef chez
monsieur météo
téhéran
non
60 70 80 400 voir où j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] que son ex principal et colette
je vous le dis tout de suite non il me
faut tout je lui dis que sinon je lui
envoyais l'huissier tu auras louette
demain ça va je connais la chanson el
pais où elle part combien
qu'est ce que vous faites là pour tout
vous dire je vais à san francisco a
acheté une grenouille à mon paquet
contient donc 550 dollars plus une
différence
vous venez
tu a interviewé des célébrités déjà oui
vous prenez toujours autant de clés vis
à vis me tue pas venu pour ça
vous êtes jeune vous avez une action qui
avait en reportage à faire sur wine
maker votre chat ne m'intéresse pas plus
que vous racontez je viens à peine de
faire sa connaissance un sujet de
société d'enfer vous pourriez la filmer
en train de laver ses petites culottes
dans le lavabo aux éditions aviez besoin
d'argent je roulais avant ce set au
point final j'en ferai une époque qui
vous a donné l'autorisation d'intervenir
dans mes parents entre vocal mai est
marqué comme ça que je t'allonger
billets de banque en veux tu en voilà
comme si j'étais votre fils ou une fille
ramassés dans la rue et tout ça devant
ces salles sont doucement là doucement
vous travaillez pour moi vous vous en
allez sur un coup de fil
vous oubliez de me demander si ça ne me
dérange pas de nous envoyer un fax pour
demander d'argent je pas droit de me
poser des questions de me rendre cet
immense service pour que j'ai une dette
envers normalement j'ai eu le tort
toutes les copines que j'ai eus sont
persuadées qu'elles doivent tout à nec
loi ne m'intéresse pas
moi je voulais nous sortir le temps je
me rappelle que je disais alwan on aura
un appartement dans l'upper west side
parce que j'avais lu un magazine qui
disait que c'était la fête diane sawyer
avait le sien alors que je ne savais
même pas où était l'eau ben woodside
tout ce que je savais ce qu'il fallait
que j'arrive et voilà un beau matin m
appliqué à dieu le père ouais ça vous
intéresse énormément
luan souhaite que je reste un peu avec
elle
j'aurai besoin de quelques jours
si vous êtes d'accord vient
en ce qui me concerne aucun problème
imagination
rester aussi longtemps que nécessaire
j'aurais voulu éviter l'ivg
ça change quoi
il ne tenait aucun compte du fait que
cette société était l'ombre à la peur la
haine la violence
nous n'avons pas abordé les canaux
les servants comme le pinson est présent
que le direct johnatan soit la politique
du président en matière d'environnement
illustre bien cette formule les sud
vietnamien ou bombarder leurs propres
positions aujourd'hui incendiant au
napalm àmilan où les habitants étaient
massacrés alors qu'il tentait de fuir
de nombreuses questions se posent après
ce terrible attentat qui a coûté la vie
à 200 marines un bilan encore provisoire
tout d'abord pourquoi un périmètre de
sécurité va vite il va y installer faut
prévenir ce type d'attentats suicide
quel rôle les marines et est il appelé à
jouer dans ce pays ravagé par la guerre
dont on ne sait même pas pourquoi ils
étaient là
au terme de cette terrible journée ce
qui est sûr c'est que 200 marines sont
morts sans savoir pourquoi
c'était voir une justice privée s en
direct les routes
barak justice a démissionné de son poste
correspondant dix bsa la maison blanche
journaliste de talent couvert de
récompenses justice travailler pour yves
et ce depuis de nombreuses années alors
c'est comment travailler sur une grande
chaîne
on s'imagine qu'en renvoyant tous ceux
qui nous en ont fait page et on pourra
enfin leur dire je t'emmerde
c'est pas du tout ça commençait à la
dure marrant pourquoi êtes vous parti je
ne m'amusais plus vous parlez moi des
concours de beauté que vous discutiez
avec tony tony peut tenir
qu'est-ce qui vous amuser plus expliqué
marc et moi du concours les concours les
concours
mais si rami straw qui me tao miss
débardeur ou pièces de crêpes copier ça
fait déjà beaucoup de secrets maintenant
le vrai secret c'est que pas une fois je
n'ai fini dans les cinq premières
qu'est ce que vous faisiez sur scène
vous chantiez feeling ce nom puisque
vous voulez le savoir ce n'est pas cette
chanson que j'interprétais brûlé tu ne
peux aussi bloqué
partir ou fait tort de ne pas aimer
jusqu'à la déchirure
et
mais vouloir sans fard et sans âme
m
le téléphone rouge carl savard à wells a
au magazine more elle voudra sûrement
pas en parler loup dallas car on voit là
un sujet ils sont massacrés nous avons
des images d'un pauvre loup pris au
piège vous à leurs reportages là dessus
passez le à 6 heures selon la police--
plainte pour vol déposée par des
touristes sont en augmentation de 10 %
elle n'intéresse pas les gens d'ici ça
ne concerne pas d'un estime adam les
gens d'ici ne veulent pas se sentir
concerné ni ans je pense que talent y
est moins en ville avec la phase que moi
si je peux me permettre
tu veux dire en phase avec la ville
naturellement je crois qu'on peut être
on parlait un v6 tout en charge et ça te
faudra peut-être pris sait-on jamais
personne la bonne surprise pour moi en
moi moi il ya un travesti originaire de
tallahassee qui a pu arriver jusqu'en
finale au concours de miss floride
devenu l'ont secoué le monde pourquoi
pas ta liste un sujet pour toi ça oui ah
non c'est vrai je t'assure je suis
certain que tu fasses à la perfection
je vois cela dit si le travesti de
tallahassee rêvons d'un impossible en
tête à six at war c'est vrai ballet
quelqu'un autre chose
voilà c'est chez moi quoi tu laisses le
scanner bon chien permanent et ça me
berce la rumeur d'hectares humaine
tu sais ce que c'est 1 502 conduite en
état d'ivresse
son influence de stupéfiants et d'alcool
skylight cb limousine de location il
travaille avec le showbiz
sans doute une grosse prise is it
aléatoire
tu devrais déjà être
le soir où on monte le sujet sur diaz
5' rédaction je ne te connaissais pas
encore
je ne veux surtout pas être celui à
cause de qui renonce à la gantoise side
alors qu'en penses tu
première sur les lieux interview
exclusive avec le chanteur saissac tu
veux ou écriture quoi
j'étais sûr que tu aimerais ici salut à
toi tu heures qui vous souhaite une
bonne et heureuse année sur wm yann
lechelle le véritable coeur de la
riviera américaine
donnez-nous 30 minutes et nous vous
donnerons miami et el mundo
tu as déjà eu affaire à baky terra nova
non un imprésario ne s'intéresse pas au
petit personnel
il vit à miami dans une semaine pour un
débat et aura aussi johanna khalili dis
donc tu dois avoir une
vous n'êtes pas tu vois ce que je veux
dire non c'est bien ce que je pensais
non parce qu'en général ça se termine
par des larmes ne s'inquiète pas
personne de la pleurer et toujours en
général ce n'est pas lui qui pleure ça y
est vous l'avez filmés alors maintenant
vous me filmer mois il aussi fernando en
juillet vous avez été condamné pour vol
à main armée il s'agissait de votre
troisième condamnation non quatrième et
donc vous venez de gagner de nombreux
prix allant de couches gratuite et une
magnifique layette le tout pour comment
allez vous l'appelez ferme du tout on a
toujours voulu l'appeler belmondo comme
moi ils ont félicité paul smith aux bb
race triste certes ali cette affaire oui
mais il se trouve qu'elle a une suite je
viens juste d'être informé que les
commerçants ont décidé étant donné les
circonstances un peu inhabituel que tous
les cadeaux qu'ils offrent si
généreusement reviendrait cette année à
la petite typhaine hippolyte chèque
voilà
à l'hôpital kaiser s'est pas ennuyé
ferme construite et sont très fiers on
les comprend le papa travaille chez
s'aggrave baisse mais si fine et que le
deuxième bébé l'aller gates devait
revenir au premier micoud rim et je
comprends les commerçants en baisse de
bac giang ça ne m'étonne pas de vos
robes bonne année la pub non c'est pas
possible en algérie dans la seconde
après tout ce monsieur bouton ça est un
repris de justice bien connu de la
police et la mère a deux enfants hors
mariage
qu'est ce que vous entendez par l'art
l'art est payant ça suffit il est
inutile de s'appesantir d'agir tué deux
caméras se trouve mans autre chose
je ne veux plus les arrêter
rob dans un esprit d'impartialité pour
conserver tout ce que cette tradition et
de force symbolique
je crois pouvoir annoncer que notre
chaîne w est bien ne manquera pas de
récompenser le véritable lauréats
bernanke dit aux moutons ce sera tout
pour ce soir cette erreur c'est les
vannes et tali atwater qui se joint à
moi pour vous souhaiter une bonne année
et beaucoup de courage de la part de
toute notre équipe
attention série
trop c'est trop coupent les micros il
faut tenir encore quinze secondes
s'étaient tombés un journal je ne savais
pas tuer chargée de veiller à la morale
publique
lui c'est un repris de justice est elle
une [ __ ] si tu vois ce que je veux dire
il n'ya que l'étudiant des vidéos
remariage d'aller trop loin
les souris et mails en veilleuse robe tu
es toujours un autre n'oublie pas de
souris mais il faut que je vous parle
nous c'était flagrant ce soir elle n'a
pas la maturité la propulser trop vite
pas protégé il n'a pas la maturité c'est
via ce que tu ai dit si tu te dire que
ton brushing donne de la maturité
tu fais de consulter ce qui signifie
gérer l'imprévu c'est ça faire de la
télévision
elle a exagéré on n'a pas le droit de
quoi de dire la vérité ou de l'adapter à
la demande de l'opinion vous savez aussi
bien que moi qu'elle est sorti de son
devoir de réserve ce soir c'est cet
accord à plus de 1000 mètres en bail
au-delà m ont pas d'âne oui mais alors à
quel pas le vôtre peut-être qu'il n'est
pas moi je le ferais tu allais la
prochaine fois tu démissionnes avant de
tourner la chaîne aurait dit que je
démissionne je voudrais bien aussi que
tu te mettre dans le crâne qu'on
n'attend pas d'être direct pour changer
de ligne éditoriale qu'à moi que tu dis
ça à moi à bayon l'équipe mais j'en
ferai jamais partie cette équipe et
pourquoi parce que malgré tous les
efforts et tous les compromis que je
préfère je serai toujours pas protégées
c'est comme ça voilà je me sens tout à
fait capable de trouver un job où je ne
serai plus là protégé de personnes
les 5 et 9 ans
tu as raison ma soeur a eu un enfant
avec un site qui a fait de la taule
alors c'est une [ __ ] tu as encore réseau
c'est un couple ce mec c'est un
présentateur
m
supernova camille jeune hacker nelly
vous vous rappelez vous connaissez vous
qui depuis longtemps nous à venir on ne
se connaît pas vous voulez que je vous
présente ce qui vient voir exclu d'aller
à toi cher monsieur petit tir à 9 h
le véritable coeur de la riviera
américaine d'aller moins 30 minutes
nous vous donnerons elmundo je me
demandais quand vous entriez dans le jeu
tout prix je voudrais une suite wilshere
et un pass pour accéder aux vestiaires
non non ça n'a pas d'importance dit que
c'est pour le jour les lakers joue
contre l'équipe de phoenix les l'essonne
non je vous rappelle sexe et drogue la
face cachée du basketball et de ses
milliardaires d'une grande enquête de
jeunes à kennedy
tous ces grands milliardaires en short
vont t'adorer tue encore très joli cul
mais là s'il n'est pas cette année ni de
l'année dernière j'ai 7 ans et 3
douzaine de petits plus de retard si je
puis dire et je suis sûr que la
prochaine fois que je te verrai ça fera
quatre douzaines sauf si tu me dis que
celle ci est différente
sans blague quelqu'un a mis le grappin
dessus ça y est c'est parce que tu crois
c'est juste une grande amitié ça c'est
nouveau
quel effet ça c'est
c'est bon
tu le suivra quand elle va bouger
un besoin sur une chaîne importante de
préférence aux heures de grande écoute
pour imposer votre image philadelphie
qu'en penseriez vous quoi une grande
ville de pennsylvanie
je peux vous y faire engueuler les
quatrièmes en parts de marché à ses
joueurs j'ai justement un nouveau visage
et ça tombe mieux notre voix et pleines
d'argent voulait jamais dit
oh
corps julian vie avec où tu viens et je
sais où tu vas j'imagine qu'il te dit
que ta voix étaient pleines d'argent ce
qu'il dit toujours il est connu pour sa
non même dit à chaud n'a d'ailleurs ce
n'est même pas lui c'est dans un roman
sa voix était plein d'argent tel est l
inépuisable charme qui émanait d'elle
hemingway c'est ça et scott fitzgerald
c'est le pardon
c'est ce que tu as tenu à faire
ba qui est loin d'être bête et ça tombe
très bien
en tout cas on aura bien rigoler toi et
moi
e
dis moi ce que tu veux toi
tu sais ce que moi je
tu veux aller à philadelphie non
et là il me dit si vous avez besoin d'un
mentor perino
pourrait venir avec moi à migrer une
semaine à philadelphie deuxième prix de
semaine philadelphie elle est connue je
suis déjà passé par là tu sais qu'il
pourrirait si non pourquoi je te le dis
déjà tout ce que tu m'as dit c'est que
ça va nous et puis ça m'a amusé pendant
un temps et puis j'ai commis une faute
et sartre de foot
j'avais un informateur qui j'avais
confiance j'ai a percuté le deux c'est
un fou je me suis grillé les
informateurs font parfois de
l'intoxication
j'aurais dû me méfier les comprendre on
a le droit de commettre une erreur
quelques fois pas vraiment quand on
choisit d'être un franc tireur
on n'a pas le droit à la moindre erreur
pourquoi tant d'attenté pour revivre ça
parce que ça aurait été encore plus dur
d'arrêter on a un peu de temps au tu
t'en ailles
le paillis messi